Bộ y tế để sốt tặng mức phạt lên tới 1 trong tríệu đồng với hình vi lửa trọn dự tình thái gì
thay vì mức 3 mì trẻ ở nhẹ này, đây là nội dung lội bà trong dự thảo lời dân số đất lấy ý kiến
nhằm ở phó tình trạng mất cân bằng dưới tính khi xin kéo dài hơn một thập kỳ
tệ số dự tính khi xin xúc bình hiện ở mức hơn 1 trong mì 2 bè chai trên 1 trong bè gái
nếu không có dải pháp mạnh đến năng hành hình không trong năm bơi, Việt Nam có thể dư 2 phải 3, đến 1 phải 3 tríệu năm dưới trong rượu tựa kết hôn
cùng với tăng chí tài sự phạt bộ y tế để sốt công hài được kỳ dành xe các biểu phương có tì lệ dự tính khi xin chất lệ
sức sật thành trạc cơ sở y tế, dự lấy nghiêm hành vi tế lộ dịch thái gì và đẩy mạnh chuyến thông số bỏ định kiến trọng năm.
Dự luật cũng để sốt bỏ dưới hạn số con cho phép người dân tự quyết định về sinh lửa, một tiêu đến hành hủ trong bà bơi
đưa tệ dù dưới tính khi xin về dưới 1 trong bè chai trên 1 trong bè gái
đảm bảo vệ sinh có lọc quình tự nhiên không bị chí phối bởi định kết dưới.